so this company is ripping off our
number one video of all time why is
Google letting this happen how do we
stop this guy like
[Music]
hey guys are you about to click away
because you think that this is an
advertisement today's sponsors today's
sponsor of today's sponsor today's
sponsor this is a sponsor segment
shame on you it's not but I did want to
bring up something that you might not
even know is happening we've all seen
pre-rolls on Facebook and Instagram and
YouTube and what-have-you where an
advertisement pops up before you watch
video it's one of the ways that we
generate revenue to continue to make
more videos if you guys have been
watching this channel for a while you
probably know that I'm a licensed
attorney and I've talked a lot about
content and copyright infringement in
the past but today's video explores
something much more nefarious okay we
got sent a numerous emails about this
and they were saying hey guys this
company that has these lucid dreaming
masks is using Superman with a GoPro as
an advertisement for a product are you
guys related to this product at all and
not only have they taken our Superman
with a GoPro video they've taken content
from numerous other creators they've cut
together in a minute and a half ad and
then they've posted that on their
Facebook profile and then they tell
Facebook hey we'll pay you money put
this video as a pre-roll all over your
site now with everything going on around
kovat and the unemployment rate and all
the other problems that are associated
with that whole mess this might not seem
like the biggest deal but as a content
creator and on behalf of the other
content creators who make the videos
that you watch those videos are our
product and when somebody takes our
product and uses it in a manner that we
don't intend that hurts us and it hurts
you guys as the viewers to the hardest
part is that this isn't the first time
that this has happened not even in the
least I mean just a few months ago Nico
was dealing with something just like
this at the studio Sam show you
something
[Music]
see this now yes the past so there's
exam it's making like minecraft mod
ripoff programs on Android and they're
using our minecraft video as their
commercial they should do that because
that's stupid and their mod probably
sucks
it's actually not a mod it's just they
took other people's mods and made a
program that let's see like install mods
on Minecraft Pocket Edition without
having to pay for them it's one thing to
like using obscure videos video of ours
but like to use our like number one
video and just rip us off or their own
commercial and now at the face of their
crappy company and their crappy app
they're ripping us off to ripping off
the modders they ripping off the
customers knowing youtube there's
probably not much we can do about it so
I think they like like hey here's
something cool I want to share it
something to like here's something cool
I want to monetize it because I want to
make money from other people's work
that's not cool
I'd like to send them an invoice and
make them pay for using it let's see if
what Jake says we can do about this we
need my lawyer so how do you stop
something like this from happening well
first and foremost when you guys the
viewers tell us about it when you see it
happening that is the most immediate way
that we find out about it but it's also
the most manual it's the slowest because
what we have to do is we have to then go
to the product search around the
internet try to locate where the video
is coming from and then ask the people
who take it down do you think we'd send
an invoice like here's the price for
using our content sending them an
invoice for a thousand dollars isn't
gonna do anything at all like you're
talking about somebody that probably
lives somewhere in some major city in
Vietnam in order to keep for you to
advertise on YouTube you have to upload
the video to YouTube if they downloaded
the video from YouTube and then re
uploaded it to YouTube why didn't
Content ID recognize that why is Google
letting this happen there is no way to
tell the platform that somebody is doing
this and so even if we go after mr. King
D himself and he takes it down the door
is still open for other people to do
this so ultimately the responsibility I
think
lies with Google if you're a company
like Facebook or Google and YouTube
you've got billions of pages literally
and you've got billions of ad dollars
coming through your site every year you
have a you have a responsibility to look
after the advertisements and the way
that they're run on your platform and
ensure that things are running smooth
and that things are playing by the rules
because right now it doesn't matter
where you got the content from you can
just go on there and put it in from a
millions of people depending on how much
money you're willing to spend now you
might be thinking Jake how is this
different than what you guys did with
the Superman properties do you don't own
the rights to Superman you don't own the
rights to Minecraft and you used those
characters in those worlds and a bunch
of different videos well the answer lies
in what is called fair use now well this
is not an affirmative right within
American copyright it is a
well-recognized
defense of additional creativity that
goes into one's work now obviously in
Superman with the GoPro we started with
the Superman character of what we do not
own but then we took it and we created
an entirely new video from an entirely
new perspective that people hadn't
really seen before and the focus wasn't
really on Superman it was on the
perspective of what it's like being
Superman it might not sound like much it
might sound like so what's the
difference you still took it and used it
and did whatever you want with it but
there's actually a huge distinction to
be made between that and then simply
taking someone else's video re uploading
it within your own advertisement and
selling your own product based on that
video I think you get what I mean
I think we can do about it outside of
like I hoping that you know big old
Google like somehow changes corporate
policy for us is there anything you can
do about someone driving like a maniac
on the freeway honk at them I mean I
guess we could do the equivalent of honk
at them and maybe give them the finger
you could maybe ask the audience to go
give bad reviews on the app I don't like
mob justice
I hate mob justice it's such a thing on
the internet now everybody just takes a
couple of facts they run with it and
they like destroy someone's career and I
don't want to like inspire mob justice
where it's like guy let's go just like
destroy this person but how do we stop
this guy like alright here's here's what
I think we should do we're gonna send
them an email and say cease using our
video immediately and tell us once
you've done so if we do not hear back
from them it's on the horn I ask people
to start reporting them for violation
don't look up their address don't send
them Molotov cocktails in the mail I
don't think you can do that
so those emails off to date be posted I
need a way to de-stress very thing AMD
stress within this office this is a
crash pad crash pad is what you can jump
onto from high distances and not hurt
yourself Oh
for that you need a big you know
watching back through this footage which
we shot long before any of this
coronavirus stuff even started it made
me realize how lucky we are to make the
videos that we make and that's due in no
small part to our loyal patrons over at
patreon.com slash court or digital
patrons like glitch cube not a Canadians
by Alan Almanza Philip Oxford Harris
Bret's of pocket
Jordan mattes bot Kurt Sunil s Daniel
Webster and Philip women thank you for
supporting new content is safe the brain
doesn't have brain damage
he's just always like that oh you have
to do though right we jump off the job
yeah
you scared room yeah bikini on any
longer
check this out she went up there
it's been a few hours since I sent off
the original emails asking these people
to remove these videos and fortunately
the people from lucid dream masks Co got
back to me and they said we reviewed all
of our content and we will take down all
the posts and videos that contain the
footage we want you to know that our
intention wasn't to deliberately steal
clips from your videos and we can assure
you that this won't happen again thank
you very much I totally understand you
know when a company is new you're trying
to get started you see a cool piece of
video out there I really appreciate that
realistically the solution to these
types of problems clearly lies with
platforms like Facebook regardless of
who creates the content or where it
comes from or who owns it if you guys
like this video and you want to know
more about what goes on here at corridor
we have a podcast where all we do is
tell stories talk about projects we're
working on things we think are funny
things we think are interesting it's a
great time if you're into podcasts head
on over to youtube.com slash cord or
cast or or click the link in the
description right here or over there the
link here anyway we just said seam icon
check it out
don't feel like you actually get
yourself you didn't take it back back up
not for I gotta go though I gotta go
I'll catch you guys back